From sleeper hits like It Comes At Night to
box-office record-breakers like It and Get
Out, 2017 has been a great year for horror.
But for every high-profile killer clown, there
are a dozen low-key horror movies that slip
straight onto DVD or — more frequently these
days — video on demand.
Here are the under-appreciated horror movies
you may have missed in 2017.
The Devil's Candy
Mixing heavy metal and horror, The Devil's
Candy follows a struggling artist, played
with an unsettling creepiness by Ethan Embry,
who moves his family out to rural Texas.
When the previous owner of their new house
starts making sinister nighttime visits, the
family's already turbulent lifestyle descends
into terror.
The Devil's Candy made the rounds at horror
festivals in 2015, but it wasn't until 2017
that the film got a more widespread release
via video-on-demand services.
Written and directed by Sean Byrne, whose
previous film was an equally unique horror
flick called The Loved Ones, The Devil's Candy
plays with themes from old-school occult films
while confidently slipping into its own modern
take on the genre.
"Just the gas?"
The Evil Within
It's impossible to talk about The Evil Within
without mentioning writer-director Andrew
Getty, who spent more than a decade meticulously
crafting this schizophrenic passion project
before passing away in 2015, two years before
the finished film was released.
But he left us with a very well-made, highly
visual horror movie that will surely leave
viewers with some very specific nightmares.
"Someone like me."
The Evil Within tells the story of a mentally
handicapped man named Dennis, played by Frederick
Koehler, who lives with with his brother,
played by Sean Patrick Flanery.
After Dennis's reflection starts telling him
to kill people, things go downhill pretty
quickly — to put it mildly.
"Yeah.
Yeah, it's a good way of saying it I guess."
Berlin Syndrome
Stockholm Syndrome is a disturbing condition
in which someone who's been kidnapped develops
a sense of affection for their kidnapper.
The film Berlin Syndrome plays with that idea
by following an Australian tourist who has
a one-night stand with a man in Berlin, only
to find herself locked in his apartment.
The struggle that follows is pure psychological
horror that dives deep into the mindset of
survival and the subtleties of psychosis,
all anchored by a phenomenal performance by
Australian actress Teresa Palmer and a bone-pounding
musical score.
Sometimes touching, sometimes brutal, Berlin
Syndrome is definitely a trip abroad that
you won't forget anytime soon.
The Blackcoat's Daughter
Writer/director Ox Perkins' slow-burn possession
film The Blackcoat's Daughter was made in
2015, but didn't secure a release until 2017.
Starring American Horror Story's Emma Roberts
and Dexter's James Remar, the film centers
on two girls who are left at their prep school
after the rest of the kids go home for vacation.
It turns out that both girls are hiding a
secret, and events start to spiral out of
their control in the worst possible way.
If you're looking for a gore-fest filled with
jump scares, you're better off looking elsewhere.
But if you want to spend your night with an
atmospheric horror film that bleeds tension,
queue this one up.
"It's fun to be scared sometimes."
A Dark Song
You couldn't ask for a more powerful directorial
debut than A Dark Song, and Liam Gavin — who
pulled double duty as both writer and director
on this smart, engaging portrayal of ritual
black magic — is definitely a director to
look for in the future.
Gavin crafted a surreal, minimalist film that
may be one of the most technically detailed
occult movies of the last decade, if not ever.
There aren't any jump scares, and very little
blood, but the build-up over A Dark Song's
100-minute runtime is just as satisfying as
the ultimate climax.
Dig Two Graves
Not your typical horror movie, Dig Two Graves
is more of a hardboiled revenge tale.
The story centers on a young girl who makes
a pact with a group of gypsy mountain men
to bring her brother back from the dead — if
she's willing to pay the price.
This indie thriller premiered at the New Orleans
Film Festival in October 2014, then quietly
sat in the shadows until it was released online
in 2017, but it was certainly worth the wait.
Dig Two Graves blends revenge, thriller, fantasy,
and horror themes into one twisted tale of
a girl who may have to make the ultimate sacrifice
for her family.
"There are no cowards, there are no heroes,
there is only the living and the dead."
Lake Bodom
While it may look like a run-of-the-mill scream-fest,
Lake Bodom's twist is selling itself as a
teen slasher flick when it manages to be so
much more.
If you've never heard of it, don't beat yourself
up.
After a short festival run, this Finnish horror
release slipped quietly onto Shudder, a video
on demand service specializing in horror movies,
virtually ensuring that only a handful of
people outside of Finland would ever lay eyes
on it.
But for horror purists, Lake Bodom is definitely
worth tracking down.
The Void
Jeremy Gillespie and Steven Kostanski first
teamed up to write and direct the 2011 horror
comedy Father's Day, a neo-grindhouse tribute
to the ultra-violent "exploitation film" genre
that hit its peak the '70s.
Their 2017 follow up, The Void, uses the same
genre-specific cues as that film, only this
time to pay tribute to cult '80s body horror.
The Void is messy, weird, and a ton of fun.
It focuses on a police officer, played by
Aaron Poole, who finds himself trapped in
a hospital when mysterious, hooded figures
surround the building.
But while staying inside seems safe, he soon
finds that the greatest terror is living in
the bowels of the hospital itself.
"It's disgusting, like Carrie levels of blood,
like, very gross."
House on Willow Street
Admittedly one of the weaker entries on this
list, House on Willow Street may fall a bit
short of the mark in pacing, but the premise
and visual design more than make up for its
flaws.
The film is about two crooks who kidnap a
young woman in the hopes of getting a ransom
from her rich father.
Little do they know, their victim is possessed,
and soon she begins to turn the tables on
her kidnappers.
House on Willow Street doesn't do much to
defy genre conventions, but it serves very
well as a bloody fun horror romp for a lazy
evening.
The Dark Tapes
At this point, we've had our fill of anthology
films.
The fad arguably kicked off with 2012's V/H/S.
"It's not haunted, I'm sure there's a reasonable
explanation…"
Since then, we've had The ABCs of Death, A
Christmas Horror Story, Holidays, and Tales
of Halloween, to name a few.
So when an anthology film comes along that
not only exceeds expectations, but shatters
them completely, it's worth a mention.
The Dark Tapes successfully ratchets up the
terror while avoiding all the pitfalls that
have doomed so many other entries in this
genre.
If you want to be grossed out by alien monsters
and scared senseless by paranormal visitors,
The Dark Tapes is the perfect choice.
And while we're on the subject of anthologies,
2017's XX is another quality entry in this
genre — and unlike The Dark Tapes, that
one's available on Netflix.
"Wow.
That was intense."
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!